I could climb that wall over please stop  grab that elephant dude you're  embarrassing yourself you think I won't  it's time to go home I could fight a  monkey pack it in man I'll fight that  monkey it's over right there dumb  looking thing just go home I'll bet you  ten dollars I'll go in there and beat up  that monkey get him it's a federal crime  to gamble at the National Zoo  [Music]  [Applause]  one frozen cherry tart please sure you  want the four inch tart or the six inch  tart I'm so sorry you wearing a wire you  rat they made me do it they made me do  it it's a federal crime to call a frozen  cherry pie a frozen cherry tart if its  diameter is more than four inches  [Music]